and a bone found at Lake Mead is now
being investigated after the eight news
now investigators push for answers this
is a story you'll only see here from
Vanessa Murphy
The Barker family has been on a journey
to find out what happened to this bone
they found at Lake Mead in July of 2021.
I wonder about it they reached out to 8
news now after they couldn't get answers
what we uncovered a mistake was made by
at least one public agency and the bone
wasn't treated as human remains until we
stepped in that's incredible I I thought
oh they would be lost so no that's
incredible it all started after Bruce
Barker's granddaughter Kimmy made the
discovery here near South Cove in
Arizona where the Colorado River begins
to form the lake it's like oh look at
that and then I went off to my grandpa
and I go Grandpa look what I found
they reached out to the National Park
Service which responded they kept trying
to tell me is the donkey bone the
barkers handed it over and say they
never heard a thing that's when they
emailed 8 news now the Park Service told
us medical officials determined the bone
was not human so we reached out to the
Mojave County Medical examiner's Office
a manager said the office sent a photo
to a forensic anthropologist who
determined it was an animal bone and
then the bone was destroyed that's when
we started asking more questions who's
the forensic anthropologist did they
produce a report the Emmy's office said
it had no records to confirm any of this
then we obtained this Park Service
report confirming photos were sent to
the medical examiner but more
importantly the bone hadn't been
destroyed it was sitting in evidence we
know what the markers are on a human
femur that indicate uh this person is a
human and Dr Jennifer Burns is an
assistant professor at UNLV she's one of
three forensic anthropologists we
interviewed who say this is absolutely a
human femur we initially reported this
in August then in October we received a
call from the medical examiner's office
the Park Service would be handing the
bone over so it could be investigated as
human remains it's actually quite
wonderful that that ended up happening
because it would be really unfortunate
if uh the remains were never examined
and never investigated to try to
identify the person and for Barker
helping a family possibly find some
closure especially his home
you know we had a 22 year old daughter
back in 2005 who passed away and people
needed closure well we've seen the
bodies now appear in Lake Mead and you
know it's bringing families closure the
Mojave County Medical examiner's Office
finally sent this statement just hours
before our deadline saying a National
Park Service Ranger only sent photos of
a fragment different from the photos we
had and that's why the bone was
categorized as an animal bone and quote
it is unclear why there is such a huge
discrepancy in images and the actual
bone now the office is working to
investigate and will attempt to identify
the remains Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now